key visualizer for cloud spanner is a
tool in the cloud console
that helps developers and operations
teams analyze spanner usage patterns
it generates visual reports for your
databases broken down by ranges of rows
over time
and it provides insights into usage
patterns at scale that are difficult to
understand otherwise
i'm going to walk you through how to use
key visualizer to look at usage patterns
for a spanner database that's used by an
application i'm working on
i've recently inherited the
responsibility for this application
and i'm not very familiar with it yet
first let's get acquainted with the key
visualizer interface
when you access key visualizer you'll
see a scan
the core of the key visualizer scan is
the heat map
the heat map shows us the value of a
metric over time
broken down into ranges of row keys the
x-axis represents time and the y-axis
represents
row ranges low values are cold
represented by darker colors like purple
and high values are hot represented by
yellow or bright white for the highest
values
the different patterns in the heat map
can help diagnose issues at a glance
each row range represents a contiguous
set of rows in a single table or index
a row range is defined by a start and
end key
within each table or index keys are
sorted by primary key values
at the top of the heat map there's a key
for the heat map colors
as you hover over a cell in the heat map
you'll see details about the value
time stamp table and key bucket
you can select a portion of the heat map
to zoom in
you can also select a time range using
the date picker
you can pan around the heat map by
clicking and dragging
you can use the select box to change
between metrics
when i look at the graph for number of
rows red i can see that the reads for
keys in the albums table are distributed
fairly evenly across row ranges
however for the singers table it's
yellow or hot across the board
and especially in the beginning row
ranges after looking at my application
code i noticed the query singer's last
name function is called frequently
i can see that we'd probably benefit
from having a secondary index on the
last name
field so that spanner doesn't have to
scan the entire table
every time query singer's last name is
called
we can do this with a create index
statement or by using force index
i'll make the change and see what
happens
with the application change deployed we
can see that the number of rows read has
dropped dramatically for the singers
table seeing a single hot table is just
one common pattern you may uncover with
key visualizer
here are some of the other patterns you
may encounter and what issues they might
indicate
a heat map with a single bright diagonal
line or a triangle with a flat top can
indicate a database that uses sequential
keys
sequential keys are an anti-pattern in
spanner and you can learn more about why
sequential keys cause
hot spots and alternatives in the
documentation on schema design best
practices
a heat map with horizontal bands of
bright color separated by dark colors
indicate that specific row ranges are
consistently being more heavily accessed
over time
to address this you can consider
changing your schema design or your
application
so that the data in a heavily used row
or in an excessively large row is spread
across
multiple rows a heat map with multiple
diagonal bright lines either rising or
falling
usually indicate sequential reads or
rights to rows in a short period of time
if the lines correspond with read
activity such as a table export
no action is usually required if you're
experiencing performance issues during
these reads
you can consider increasing the number
of nodes for your instance during those
time periods
if the lines correspond with right
activity and you're experiencing
performance issues you should consider
changing your workload
to a random write instead of a
sequential write
a heat map showing bright horizontal
bands that appear part way across the
heap map
indicate a sudden change in the usage
pattern of a database
this could be a rogue query or an
unexpected surge in activity for certain
rows
you can learn even more about exploring
heat maps and understanding heat map
patterns
in the spanner key visualizer
documentation
in this video we've looked at how key
visualizer for spanner can help you
analyze usage patterns in your spanner
databases
this tool adds to existing monitoring
tools such as query stats and monitoring
in the cloud console
to help simplify the process of
monitoring and troubleshooting
performance issues
in the description below the video
you'll find links to the key visualizer
documentation
key visualizer is now available for all
spanner databases
so start exploring